how do you advise people to deal with
threatening others in public or on a bus
or you're on a tube I'm seeing
increasing videos of these the thing
that I tell them to do is just avoid it
at all costs a lot of these
confrontations happen and it's
unnecessary it's two egos going at it
for example just happened to me
yesterday stayed at the JW Marriott and
there's a park across the street and
homeless guy asked me for something I
was like sorry man I don't have anything
and he got irate with me charged me he's
telling me I needed to stand up you
really need to be careful with people
that don't have anything to lose when
you have something to lose and so let it
go if there's any possibility of you
being able to exit that situation so get
off at the next tubes bus stop you know
I think a lot of people can't just let
it go and I mean Carrie is going to give
you that confidence especially if you
know how to use it my wife was a realtor
it took one time where she got in an
uncomfortable scenario with somebody
that wanted to come look at the house
she didn't have that never happened
again